Brent, Thomas,
congratulations.
You've made it into the
third and final round
of this competition.
Now we're sending you
back to your home forges
to recreate this iconic
weapon from history--
[tense music]
The Tizona del Cid.
Oh, my.
What is that?
Looking at the blade,
I see this super ornate
guard and pommel.
And I'm thinking, how can I
get all this in detail into it
and make it strong
and functional?
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in four days.
Good luck, brother.
Good luck.
[music playing]
Today I have to
make El Cid's Telzona.
I'm getting the tang,
drawn out but I noticed
the tang is getting twisted.
And I'm really
worried at this point
because this could
cause a lot of stress.
I will definitely have a little
catching up to do tomorrow.
[heavy metal music]
We're here in West Virginia.
Let's get these
burners a burning.
El Cid' blade is a
very light blade.
I'm really concerned about how
I'm going to keep it that way.
After a few hours of
forging, I finally
had my piece at the length.
I climb up on the
little steppy stool,
and I could barely get the tip
of this blade into the quench.
The quench went all right.
Tomorrow I have to move
on to the pretty stuff.
It's day two, and I
am going to start over.
It's pedal to the metal.
I've gotta hurry.
I absolutely need to
quench this plate tonight,
or I am going to be
drastically behind.
So I've got my blade forged
out to the shape I want.
I'm leaving my tank
bigger than I need so
that, as I'm holding this
gigantic, long piece,
it doesn't bend at the tang.
[heavy metal music]
Today I got my blade
forged and quenched.
So happy.
Today's main goal was
to get the guard assembly.
There's a lot of artistic
work involved with this piece.
This is the kind
of work I'm really
used to, these
little, small twists
and bends, basic blacksmithing.
So I've got all my welding done.
Now it's time to clean this
thing up on the grinder.
That is beautiful.
I love that.
Right now, I've
got the majority
of my guard constructed.
I have to add a little crossbar
to weld on as a cross-guard.
For the pommel, I plan on just
cutting a little cone out.
I got it nice and sharp.
My thin finish
isn't perfect, but I
made this sword in three days.
So even if you feel
like you can't do it,
just give it a shot.
You really never know
what's going to happen.
[music playing]
Here we are, the
last day of this build.
Everything has
progressed nicely so far.
Now I'm going to start the
mustard petina process.
Basically, the vinegar
and the mustard
reacts to high-carbon steel.
The blade begins to slightly
rust and wipe it off,
and you have a nice, little
outline where you mustard was.
All right.
I'm very, very, very
happy with that.
That is wild.
Before I see this
blade off, I've
just got to test it one time.
And the blade just passes
right through like hot butter.
Eat your heart out, El Cid.
We got it done.
All right, bladesmiths.
Welcome to the keel test.
To find out what kind of lethal
damage your weapons will do,
I will take your
weapon and deliver
some slashes and thrusts
on this boar carcass.
Brent, you are first.
Are you ready for this?
Yeah.
Let's do it so my knees
will stop shaking.
All right.
Let's do this.
[heavy metal music]
Wow.
Good job.
All right, Brent.
Let's talk about
your Tizona here.
The balance of this
blade allows me
to really move around with it,
and it's a very sharp edge.
Overall this weapon is one
that you can move and bring
to combat, and it will kill.
Thank you, sir.
Good job.
All right, Thomas.
Your turn.
You ready?
Ready as I'll ever be.
All right.
Let's do this.
[heavy metal music]
Nice.
Your tip thrusts easy
and cuts on the way out.
And your edge-- as you can
see, same number of cuts
cut all the way through.
Your first sword-- it will kill.
Good job.
Thank you.
It's OK to be thrilled, kid.
[laughs] Is it?
[tense music]
All right, gentlemen.
It's time for the strength
test, the armor chop.
To test the strength and overall
construction of your blades,
I'll be chopping into
our armored knights here.
Brent, you're up first.
You ready?
Yes, sir.
[heavy metal music]
All right, Brent.
You've got a couple
of chips and rolls.
I don't know that it'll affect
the performance of your blade.
It's still sharp.
As far as the design
of your blade,
that's a very slick handle.
I'd like to not be able
to do that as easily.
But you did good.
It's a strong sword, one piece.
Good job.
Thank you.
Tomas, are you ready?
I'm ready.
Swing away.
[heavy metal music]
All right.
Thomas, this has a
really fine edge to it.
And where it made contact,
there are multiple rolls.
That's that superfine
edge just being pushed
over as it hits that armor.
It's an amazingly light
sword for as wide as that is.
That's very good work.
I mean, it's a very
broad blade, and it's
got a very light feel to it.
The handle on this, the wrapping
on there gives a good grip.
It felt really good in my hand.
Bottom line-- it's
a strong sword.
It held up beautifully.
Good job.
Thank you.
All right, bladesmiths.
This is the sharpness
test, the fish slice.
To test the edge of
your weapon, I will
slash away at these salmons.
Brent, you are first.
Are you ready?
Let's do it.
[tense music]
[heavy metal music]
Wow.
Good job.
All right.
Let's talk about
your sword here.
It cut all the way through
the fishes except for that.
It's a sharp edge.
All the cuts here
are very clean.
Overall, sir, it will cut.
Awesome.
Thank you.
All right, Thomas.
Ready for sushi?
I am ready.
Let's do this.
It's really down to
the wire at this point.
If my blade doesn't perform as
well as Brent's, I'm definitely
out of this competition.
[heavy metal music]
Wow.
Good job.
Heck yeah.
All right, Thomas.
Every cut was clean
all the way through.
Once again, the edge here
despite some of the rolls
it took earlier, had no issues
in performance and quality
of cuts.
Overall, sir, it will cut.
All right, bladesmiths.
The new Forged in Fire
champion is Brent.
Congratulations.
You're the new Forged
in Fire champion.
Thomas, unfortunately, a
setback in your home forge
cost you a little
bit of detail when
it came to your final product.
And for that reason,
please leave the forge.
[music playing]
I'm super disappointed
that I didn't win,
but I came out here.
I made a knife with a drum set.
I made a sword for
the first time.
I'm just so proud
of myself for having
taken the risk, putting myself
outside of my comfort zone.
And right now, I feel
like a rock star.
Brent, congratulations.
You are the Forged
in Fire champion,
and that's a title that comes
with a check for $10,000.
Good job, my friend.
[applause]
Oh, it feels amazing.
The adrenaline right now is
just through the friggin roof.
I'd like to thank God
for this opportunity,
my wife for her support.
Just thank you, everyone.
I have trouble
containing everything.
There's so many emotions
inside right now that I
just want to let them all out.
Yeah!
[heavy metal music]